So after going through the cooking process, let's look at how we're
actually packaging our game now.
So as you saw at the start, we kind of just went off the default project
settings, but let's talk about the different options available to us here.
So even though there are more settings that are outside the scope
of this course, we want to highlight the development build and shipping
builders, these two options are things that you'll be using most frequently.
There are other packaging options, like I said, and I've included a link just to a
full breakdown of this in the documentation below, but let's take a look
at development and shipping first.
So the purpose of development build, I mean, as the name states, you know,
it's for internal testing and development.
We do have the shipping option and that's more for public release and distribution.
Now, that being said, there's no harm in testing shipping builds every now and
then, you know, say for every 10 builds you make, maybe one of them is shipping
or maybe you have a higher percentage, but you don't only want to be testing
development builds and then the first time your shipping build is tested is
on the end user, that's not a good process, but for the most part
development will be where you're doing your development builds and shipping
is where you're doing the shipping builds, like I said, every nine times
out of 10, maybe development, and then every 10th build, maybe shipping
or something, some kind of ratio like that, depending on your
development process, of course.
So what do we get in each of these builds?
So in development, we've got debugging and the login included.
Whereas, you know, for obvious reasons, we want to remove this
from the shipping build because we don't want our end players giving
access to any of the debug information.
In development, we do have the console commands and profiling
tools and visual debugging, which is disabled and removed in shipping builds.
For the most part, I will caveat this in that there are a few talks
online from Unreal Fest and other places about actually getting access
to some profiling in shipping builds, but you know, for the most part, this
is disabled and removed in shipping builds.
In development builds, because they're focusing on deploying the
build and not for shipping, these tend to be less optimized and it's
just focusing on the functionality and debugging, and it does have a
larger file size due to extra data.
This is why I was saying that you don't just want to be only testing
development builds, you do want to be testing shipping builds every
now and then, because they're going to be optimized for performance
on your target platforms.
It's going to be most in line with your file size because
it removes all the extra data.
So if you're looking to really squeeze out every millisecond for
your performance, or you're looking for a certain disc size download,
that's why you'd want to test your shipping builds.
You really want to know what the end user is experiencing and seeing.
So, you know, development builds are there for the purpose of faster
iteration, but they will be less optimized and have a larger
file size because of that.
Now for the development builds, you should not be deploying or
distributing these development builds.
I mean, you obviously can do, but it's not intended for public release.
But the deployment is simpler.
Whereas the shipping build, once you finish your project
and it's ready to ship, this is intended for public release
and, you know, platform specific packaging and your DRM.
So hopefully that gives you a good overview of the two
different build options and why you might use one over the other.
So as I mentioned at the very start of this course, hopefully you could
have just gone to package your project, clicked package for windows
and everything would have worked great.
And that's the course over and done with, and you don't need
to listen to my voice anymore.
But some of you will have experienced broken builds and it may not package
right out of the box and it may not be as easy as I made it seem.
So if you, if you do get errors, how do I fix these errors?
Hopefully we can get into all of these things to help you out.
So packaging, when you're working on games should be run at regular intervals.
We should be able to package at least, you know, weekly and
not run into build errors.
And this will help you clean errors as you go.
If you're on a three month game project and you only wait till
month 28 to package, that's probably not ideal.
You just want to be keeping these builds going as frequently as you can.
So just get ahead of errors, especially if you're working with any,
you know, downloaded content or any files where you have people
that aren't as familiar with Unreal developing or anything like this.
You really want to, any large project changes, you want to make
sure everything's packaging okay.
You also want to ensure that there are no extraneous references to any
of the assets that we're using and that we're deleting anything across
the project that we're not using.
So this is kind of a common, a common occurrence that we see in
Blueprints where, you know, we're testing all these different variables.
You can see this image at the bottom, right, where I've just got this test
bool and I've got this new vector and I was just like, create this variable.
This is like, oh, I'll delete this when I'm done testing.
Like I shouldn't leave this around.
I've got my final, final variable that ends up ultimately not being my final
variable and you've just got these random variables just left behind.
I was trying to prototype something quickly.
You would be surprised at the amount of issues that these can cause.
They might be mis-referenced somewhere.
They can just cause headaches.
So where possible, you know, when you are working in Blueprints, just try
and keep things clean and organized.
It doesn't hurt to categorize your variables and keep things ordered.
But these can cause packaging issues.
So you should work with good Blueprint communication and structures, especially
when you're thinking about packaging and shipping projects here.
We can also update redirect references.
So this should be done at regular intervals as well.
But what you can do is you can click one of your subfolders here.
I would not recommend just doing the kitchen sink approach and right
clicking on the full content folder.
I would go subfolder at a time and just fix up redirectors as you go.
And just to explain what redirectors are, they're almost like
breadcrumbs left behind in Unreal Engine.
So say I made a Blueprint and I had intended to put it in the Blueprints
folder, but for some reason I put it in this audio folder.
And in Unreal Engine, what I can do is I can just move the Blueprint.
I can drag and drop it over into the Blueprints folder and it'll
say, do I want to move it here?
I'm like, yeah, I want to move it here.
Now what Unreal Engine will do is it'll leave an invisible
Redirector behind, you can show these redirectors in your
content browser flags, you know, the visibility flags, but essentially
they're invisible by default.
And when packaging, although Unreal Engine knows that your Blueprint is
in the Blueprints folder, it first goes to the audio folder because that
was the original place that it was in.
And it says, is this Blueprint in the audio folder?
And it'll find a Redirector and it'll say, oh no, it's not in the audio folder.
It's in the Blueprints folder now.
And then, you know, that's an extra process that Unreal has to go through.
So then find your Blueprint to help package it.
That in itself would maybe work, you know, it's kind of project specific,
but you know, that may work.
It's not to say that all redirectors won't package, but you can imagine
this happening on multiple different occasions.
And this is why I say, don't just click your content folder.
Cause it might be redirectors or redirectors, say you've put something
in your audio folder that's moved to the character folder, that's moved to the
Blueprints folder or something like this.
And if you just right click in the content folder, Unreal might get
confused about which, which director was supposed to go in which chain.
And it starts trying to clean stuff up and you break everything.
So this should be almost like a project spring clean where you just keep this
going by spring clean, I don't mean do it once a year, do it on a frequent
basis, especially as part of your packaging process, but you want to
be updating these redirectors cause there's no, there's no need for the
most part on these projects to have the redirectors left behind.
So just make sure you're updating the redirectors as you go.
What you can do as well.
So some teams might be prototyping in a project and they may have just loads
of this, um, prototype content.
And they may just want to move to a brand new clean project.
That's just like, right.
We know that this is an empty project and we know that we want
to keep this nice and organized.
And you can actually get content across from one project to the next by right
clicking, say you want a level migrating, you can right click on a level, go
to asset actions and click migrate.
And what migrate will do is it will take that level with all of its
references across to the new, um, project.
Now this is quite a heavy handed way of doing things.
Um, it's not advised to just do this by default and it'll work
straight out of the box.
The complications that happen, it tends to work better on
LAD, a smaller asset references.
Say you've got maybe a sound queue and a sound WAV and you want to migrate
the sound queue, and then it'll take the WAV with it and it'll keep
everything referenced correctly.
That tends to work okay.
However, if it's a level with lots of referencing, it can, you
know, trip up a little bit, but if you really need to use migrate
for any reason, you know, use it sparingly use it in an organized
way, but it can help, you know, strip out some of the unused
content and into a clean project.
And then you can attempt to package that just remembering to fix up
your redirectors as well after that.
Now, um, if you are, um, if your project is, you know, uh, clean and
you're having issues, say you just download the Unreal Engine third
person template or first person template, and you try and package
that and it's not packaging.
So first, first of all, if you try to package your existing game
projects and it doesn't package, try to include, um, try to just load,
um, you know, uh, a default Epic template from the launcher.
It doesn't matter what template it is and just try and package that.
If that package is okay, then it's an issue with your game
projects and we need to go back and, you know, fix redirectors,
delete variables, do any of the house cleaning that we need
to do on that project.
However, if, if your computer isn't packaging, you know, the
first person template or the third person template, and that's
the thing that's breaking, then it'll be an issue with the
code that you've got installed.
So the first thing to do is make sure you download the
correct version of visual studio.
You could download the visual studio community, make sure you
have the purple, uh, visual studio icon and not the blue
icon, which is a visual studio code.
Make sure you have the correct SDKs installed.
Now this might be outdated as a time of watching.
I'm not sure, but essentially just check the SDKs that you need
and then maybe some SDKs involved.
Also this last, um, redistributable, um, check, check
that you've got that installed too.
So there's some helpful links.
You'll no doubt, you'll find helpful forum posts online of
just making sure you have the correct visual studio and SDKs
installed, but these are a quick go to, and then just try
packaging that default Unreal Engine template, say the third
person template, if that package is okay, then go to your game
project, check that that package is, and if not, then it'll be
something to do with your game content.
Um, so hopefully those links help, uh, when trying to
debug, uh, packaging your projects.